[Applaudissements]
et tu l'as pas molli sexuelle on y va
c'est pas cher sa vie j'ai fait un tour
dans votre hommage pourquoi parce que
j'ai trouvé ce genre 2 et d'à côté
regardez bien il y a des cartes bien sûr
mais il ya surtout des noms de famille
des chroniqueurs ici des aussi bien sûr
de gilbert et d'alex ya verdez érosion
il ya malagré amorosia nous naya lemoine
extérieur ou dialectes vous d'y
accompagner tous que peint d'ici et le
côté ya les prénoms il ya une heure à y
attirer vous pouvez l'ordre est tout à
fait différent d'ailleurs à oui c'est à
dire que pardon si je prends le roi
verdez la place et qu'il rompait le roi
c'est au super nes ici tu le regardes
par exemple ouvrage les cartes
correspondent non ma présence ici gernez
est il exactement
donc il ya correspondance mais pour le
moment c'est tout pourri c'est tout
mélanger je vous explique le truc pour
qu'on soit sûr et certain que c'est bien
mélanger deux sièges mais même leur
mélange et une fois que me soit le
bourgeoisie mais lens et arras
voilà ce que c'est vraiment bien
mélanger d'accord si jean-luc avait été
là on aurait on leur ait dit mélenchon
jean luc mélenchon jean luc mélenchon
alors retiens tu m'a touché une carte du
bout du doigt
à quoi tu touches celle que tu veux tu
n'es pas qu'on paie sa première fois
qu'on fait un tour ensemble celle là on
a fait les pacéens on a bien carte ok
parfait on la met comme ça regarde bien
des pinces sans rire comme ça regarde
bien ici vient pas de correspondance
gilbert chamerois ça n'existera avec
gilles benhaim nos cousins qui fait des
intrants combal enfin rien et 6,2 tiré
aucune correspondance morini bosc
matthew goode et on a une carte que tu
as choisie et qui est exactement celle
là que je mets de côté et je te montre
qui a toujours aucune correspondance et
regarde bien fait rire ozon parce que je
leur un élan à perdre et ils me
regardent et ça n'existe
non tu aimerais que ça existait dans son
regard bien sûr cyril j'aimerais que tu
regarde la carte que tu as choisie
qu'est ce que tu as choisi comme thème
est choisi le nom anna le moine et
regarde l'autre moitié
normalement ce serait jean luc c'est
normalement mais non et ces gens le coin
là attendez parce que s'il a fait ça
mais maintenant que ça a été choisi par
cyril que le chef d'equipe à toucher
regarder maintenant gilbert rozon jours
à rousset maintenant je suis père des
équipes
[Applaudissements]